a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo su ben dream
bravi che fate le scritte sopra le
scritte che si legge da dio complimenti
tristi alla sotto la scritta temono 9
mettiamolo sopra le altre screen
perfetto su ben dream coma è un gioco
ragazzi che somiglia tipo a
c'è un corno con un occhio nel back 9
bridge ponte
gabry ponte è la madonna cos'è sta roba
non ho idea di che cosa sia questa roba
però il menù per caso c'è una buccia un
uccello gli uccelli ti odiano bastardi
haters sangue sulla mano
ma cosa sta roba siamo su un ponte su
gabri c'è anche un verme perché shaun
verme a questo è l'impegno che esistono
gli oggetti che ho nell'inventario che
io ho un verme nell'inventario non
facciamo domande andiamo avanti allora
c'è la scritta welcome molto bella c'è
un corpo morto bellissima macchina in
miniatura che mette una macchina
telecomandata su un ponte spiegatemi chi
cazzo è quello salve sono famiglie non è
che per caso mi dai una mano che ci sono
i corpi morti
bello questo gioco allora
vabbè andiamo avanti non so che dire
proprio bello per adesso telecomando
probabilmente nella macchina di prima
però non me lo fa prete si prendono gli
oggetti regalati da silvio butto giù
roba sono un vandalo sono un santo nato
corpo ha previsto gioco ci sono i corpi
morti va bene for words da dio che sta
roba
praga non sto capendo per bellissimi
pezzi di giornale
boh io sono sempre più vandalo perché
escono ragni da quella scarpa non
tocchiamo lavora si capisce una chiave a
noi la lente di ingrandimento nato la
lente di ingrandimento fantastico ma
chiaro questa è una chiave vera invece
perfetto chiave della macchina non
possono andare oltre c'è un calzino sul
ponte ore non posso andare oltre perché
non posso oltrepassare il ponte e cioè
verme io per la chiave la pesca dove
ammette non so come funzionano gli
oggetti o non me lo metto lente
d'ingrandimento lost visitor hospital
visita al nostro ospedale
sono gli ama gli effetti sonori chi li
ha messi topo gigio molto meglio io
leggo i giornali con la lente di
ingrandimento che non ci lega un cazzo
senza perché non possiamo svegliarci dal
da dove acqui questo sogno
c'è una batteria sul corpo che questo
corpo andava aprile però si sono
scaricate e morto va beh devo mettermi
fair batteria dentro
no però ci ho provato ma ecco che culo
il telecomando perche adesso posso usare
il telecomando per guidare la macchina e
fuggire da qua sono sicuri sì ma magari
magari mi fai vedere cosa sono pilotando
e grazie arca non vedo niente per forza
accese scemo è voler mischiare scusa zia
e non volevo lente d'ingrandimento
marecchia c'era un uomo in miniatura
ubriaco dentro la macchina in miniatura
non mi date mai ragazzi dopo che avete
bevuto soprattutto nelle macchine in
miniatura che non va bene per niente
posso aprire le quindi le chiare le
chiavi della macchina per aprire il
bagagliaio di una macchina in miniatura
non fa una piega un piede di porco
dentro una macchina in miniatura quindi
un piede di porco in miniatura no vabbè
[Applauso]
sono un [ __ ] genio posso andare sul
ponte adesso attraverso attraverso
veloce veloce nemica mia nonna che ha
scolato la pasta veloci be loved veloci
fonte sega al terremoto ma c'è un altro
corpo morto tanto per cambiare va bene e
sento un haters che si lamenta in questo
momento perché ma scavalca store alaba
amica una sbarra dio santo che ne frega
se non c'è il telepass madonna le capace
e pigro non è capace di scavalcare una
sbarra va bene chi è che piange sud ice
che vi fa vj sotto i miei video che
smetti di piangere
qualcosa mi dice che non è quello che
penso non era quello che pensavo ma
proprio a zero come si spegne questa
cosa così si spegne occhio che quei
bambini non funziona questa cosa con
cavo preso cavo attivo a lo metto dove
c'era la sbarra prima ok non ha un
attimo però non è possibile che non ho
capito chi non si stacca di una lei da
dove ho messo il piede di porco di prima
era qua
c'è un barbone pelle queste nuove nike
air max charles salve
salve c'è qualcuno che fuori ci sono io
se ti toglie la benda mi vedi se non te
la togli magari no ho bisogno di aiuto a
voi che ti aiuti snodare la benda
ho trovato queste carte potresti darci
un'occhiata per me perché tutto non le
vedi nav è giusto ok dami che cosa
faccio il notaio cos'è sta roba che
problemi hai zio spiega mi devo trovare
le cose che mancano ma cosa io tele
trova anche zio ma mi spieghi l'utilità
di tutto questo va bene la showgirl non
ha un senso tutto questo però va beh ha
fatto sono bravo io facevo la settimana
enigmistica con mia zia quando ero
piccolo quindi sono sono bravo sono
skillato ancora basta
inter a comprare la settimana
enigmistica solola 6 fa il caso è da me
qua guarda qua guarda non fa il banano
farmi incazzare guarda e pensa peggio di
quanto pensassi si è decisamente peggio
premier al piede di porco e lasciami da
solo si debba bard ti voglio più vedere
levati dar cazzo presto per il porco
preso l'ho preso via gabelli voglio più
vedere tu non vedi ma io non ti voglio
più vedere
ha iniziato a piovere taran g
perché c'è un cane buono fido bo buono
mi togliete stoccare di mezzo fra te e
c'è un cane non so se è tuo ma gli ho
potuto tutto soprattutto caricari
dopotutto qualsiasi cosa ma lavora in
assoda l'aloe un tappo di bottiglia no è
un cacciavite un amo molto la una maul
amo la maul uso per questo la juve si
vabbè mica devo costruire a canna da
pesca ma li mortacci tua
cosa pesco mica esce fuori chernobyl da
un pesce pesce marcio e va bene
sicuramente sano non poteva essere vabbè
dato già mangiucchiato fantastico idoneo
one pesce marcio
era giusto non saperlo pesce marcio ai
cani fantastico o un'ora e mezza perché
sarà scappata stata una vestita
cosa allora
non so cosa sia questo rumore non
facciamoci domande veloci il cavo il
cavo cavo qua dentro
adesso no cacciavite veramente
adesso posso passare no perché prima che
era attesa non potevo scavalcarla no non
capisco io non ne capisco che cosa lega
pro va bene
[Applauso]
ti serve una mano perché è spuntato un
verme gigante mi ha staccato mezze dita
che succede ciao frate cosa stai facendo
qui e niente cercando di parlarti perché
sei capovolto e quindi non è ancora il
momento giusto di dici di no
torna più tardi va bene va bene lo tiene
sangue alla testa fare così non gli
viene sangue la testa famosi e lo evaso
difficoltà a è finito è finita questa è
la fine della demo barboni cani che
mangiano pesci marci bambole ma mani con
poche di capello questo gioco dei bravi
robert carisolo boschi bravissimo vabbè
ragazzi questo era plaid dream coma
grazie ragazzi per ha visto il video
spero che vi sia piaciuto spero che
abbiate imparato che per distrarre i
cani randagi dei barboni bisogna dargli
il pesce marcio che perfetto e i ragazzi
sperabili sia piaciuto cose già mi è
piaciuto il momento è mi piace anche ma
risorsa che come invito totale tiziana
sensi di siete riusciti vediamo il
prossimo video è da ragazzi